شيرين تطلق سهامه على انغام واليسا
والجمهور يعلق هجوم غير مبرر وقرار مفاجئ
من الاتحاد الاسباني في ازمه فينيسيوس
الغاء البطاقه الحمراء وتزامنا مع اولى
بطولاته السينمائيه الفنانه الشاب تيام
قمر ضيف تفاعلكم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
انه الجدل بيتقصدها الفنانه شيرين خلال
الفتره الماضيه ما بتخرج من دائره الجدل
ابدا فمن بعد مسلسل زواجها والطلاق
والعوده وازمه مرضها وكل ما تبعد ذلك ومن
بعد حفل دبي واللي صار فيه اخر حلقات جدل
شيرين ظهورها من ايام في برنامج كاربول
كاريوكي بالعربي مع هشام الهويش على قناه
دبي وهجومها اللي بصراحه ممكن نوصفوا بغير
المبرر ضد بعض زميلاتها البدايه كانت في
سؤال هشام للشرير اذا هي الوحيده اللي
بتستحق لقب صوت مصر وشيرين ردت عليه نعم
نعم ونص
اهلا بصوت مصر يا مرحبا بك
هل انت الوحيده التي تستحق هذا اللقب
جاوبيني بدعم او لا نعم الله اكبر الله
اكبر ما اقدرش
يا سلام على الثقه بالنفس ميه ميه
ادي الاجابه اشعلت غضب جمهور النجم الكبير
انغام واللي لقب صوت مصر مرتبط فيها من
زمان واطلق عليها كثيرا في حفلات ولقاءات
وتصريحات وزاد اكثر ارتباط اللقب فيها من
بعد حفل ليله صوت مصر في الرياض من اسابيع
واللي تكرمت فيها النجمه عن نجمه
المسيرتها وغنت لاكثر من خمس ساعات في حفل
مبهر يعني صراحه انا حضرت الحفل وفعلا كان
حفل روعه يعني كان فعلا رائع طيب خلينا
نرجع لتصريح شيرين فجمهور انغام استغرب من
تصريح شيرين خاصه نبره التحدي اللي فيه
وتحديدا ان نعم ونص ودخلوا تويتر عبروا عن
ارائهم وكسروا الدنيا بهاشتاج انغام صوت
مصر
الفنانه انغام كعادتها في مواقف من هذا
النوع ما ردت لكنها اكتفت على تويتر
بمجموعه من الريتويت لتغريدات مثل اللي
شفتوها لمغردين ومحبين بيعلقوا على
الموضوع وبيسموها صوت مصر الاول والاخير
الهجوم الثاني اللي اطلقته شيرين في نفس
اللقاء كان ضد اليسا اللي قالت انها بتحب
وضوحها لكن ما بتحب فيها انها على المسرح
بتغني وكانها ماسكه على الجمهور شيكات
بحب
وضحى هي واضحه قوي في الوش
وما بحبش ساعات ان انا ان هي لما بتغني
بحس ان هي ماسكه على الناس شيكات
واخده عليهم
بس هي واضحه وجميله وقلبها حلو
فعلا الناس شيكات يعني بتغني وهي محمل
الجمهور جميله يعني او مسويه فيهم كده
معروف يعني اللي ردت على شيرين ونشرت
التغريده اللي شايفينها واللي فيها صورتين
واحده لها على المسرح ومكتوب فوقها ايش
الجمهور بيشوفو وانا واقفه على المسرح
وهنا اليسا بتتكلم عن نفسها طبعا والصوره
اللي جنبها لوحدها ماسكه شيك ومكتوب فوقها
هذا اللي شيرين بتشوفه لكن اليسا حرصت في
تغريدتها انها تكتب
وهو تعبير انجليزي ممكن نترجمه انه يعني
من غير زعل او ماني شايله في قلبي شاي
وحطت كمان ايموجي وهي بتضحك
[موسيقى]
تطورات متسارعه بنسمعها وبنشوفها في واقع
التعرض اللاعب البرازيلي فينيسيوس لاهانات
عنصريه خلال مباراه ريال مدريد مع فالنسيا
بالدوري الاسباني واللي انتهت بطرد
فينيسيوس من المباراه الواقع هذه تحولت
لازمه عالميه دخلت فيها رئاسه البرازيل
واتحادات دول وانديه وشركات ولاعبين بداوا
في التضامن مع اللاعب اللي على فكره مو
اول مره بيتعرض للعنصريه والان اللي صار
في المباراه اتضحت صورته الى حد كبير
فخلال المباراه تعرض فينيسيوس عنصريه وتم
وصفه بالقرد والجمهور صار يقلد صوته حتى
وتوجه وقتها فينيسيوس للجماهير وشخص
تحديدا كان بيوصفه بالقرد وقال له هذا انت
وبعدين اشتكى للحكم وقفت المباراه عشره
دقايق ودخل في نوبه بكاء وقال ما ابغى
اكمل لعب ونزل المدرب يهديه ويحضنه ورجعت
المباراه لكن وقت بدل الضائع اشتبك مع
لاعبين فالنسيا وطردوا الحكم بعد ما رجع
للفار وهو بغادر ارض الملعب استمرت
الهتافات العنصريه الواقعه كلها جدد
الكلام على التصدي للعنصريه في الملاعب
وهذه المره يمكن بشكل اقوى من اي مره
ثانيا الجديد اليوم من الاتحاد الاسباني
الغى البطاقه الحمراء ضد فينيسيوس خلال
المباراه وقالوا انه تقييم الحكم للي حصل
تم تحديده بعد اغفال الواقعه بالكامل وهذا
الشيء اثر على قراره في النهايه وقرر
الاتحاد كمان الاغلاق الجزئي لملعب نادي
بالانتيالي خمس مباريات قادمه وتغريم
النادي 45 الف يورو هذه العقوبه هي
العقوبه الاقوى على الاطلاق في قضيه
عنصريه في كره القدم الاسبانيه والنادي
اعتراض واستانف القرار وقال ان العقوبه
غير عادله وغير متناسبه وانه بيرفضها وشكى
كمان من انه ما اخذ فرصه يدافع عن نفسه
قبل صدور القرار كمان احنا تعاونا مع
الشرطه من البدايه وقمنا بادانه اللي حصل
في الملعب وساعدنا في تحديد هويه اشخاص من
اللي هدفوا الهتافات العنصريه ومنعنا
احدهم من دخول ملاعبنا مدى الحياه يعني
بيانهم كانهم بيقولوا يعني نعمه ليش اكثر
من كده يعني قرار الاتحاد الاسباني كمان
بخصوص الغاء الطرد وايقاف اللعب عمل حاله
من الجدل والانقسام كمان ففي ناس اعتبرت
من هذا القرار صح وما كان لازم ينطرد
فينيسيوس لانه الحكم ما طرد لاعب الانتهاء
اللي هو اعتدى هو كمان على بني وناس ثانيه
شافته خطوه في طريق مواجهه العنصريه
وعقوبه كويسه ضد النادي وفي ناس عارضت
القرار وقالت كيف تتلغي بطاقه حمراء وكان
ملفت انه في ناس اصلا داعمه الفينيسيوس
ومتضامنه معاه ضد العنصريه لكنها معارضه
قرار الغاء طرده مثل شعبي مدرب برشلونه
مثلا اللي قال انا اتضامنت معه وادمنت
العنصريه لكن ما يجوز خلط الامور وكان في
اعتداء واضح ومعرف لاي درجه الغاء الطرد
عادل وفي قسم من الناس اعتبر انه كل هذا
قرار مو مهم بقدر ما هو المهم اتخاذ خطوات
عمليه ضد العنصريه بحد ذاتها هو العنصريين
يعني ازمه جالسه بتتوسع وبتكبر وحملات
التضامن مع فيني كمان بتتوسع فمن بعد ما
دعمته شركه بومه امس اللي هي على فكره
راعي فريق فالنسيا نشرت شركه نايكي كمان
تغريده فيها صوره لفينيسيوس وعنواناتها
بنحن معك اما شعبيا ففي البرازيل كان جمع
حوالي مئه متظاهر خارج القنصليه في طالبوا
بايقاف العنصريه في اسبانيا
والبرازيل وحملوا لافتات عليها عبارات دعم
لفينيسيوس ومحاربه للعنصريه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اول مره ظهر على الشاشه كان طفل صغير وعمل
دورين صغار مع والده في فيلم قلب جريء
وبحبك وانا كمان وبعدها غب سنه وقت ورجع
يعني من كم سنه شفنا ممثل شاب موهبه لافته
بيطلب بفاجئنا حتى في ادوار عده بنتكلم
نحن تحديدا عن ايام مصطفى قمر من ليالي
الحلميه الجزء السادس لابو البنات لخيانه
عهد لاهدى اللي صار اللي زي القمر الا انا
وغيرها كمان وحقيقه هو من بين الفنانين
الشباب اللي قدروا يثبت وجودهم على الساحه
وجماهيريه كمان يحجزوا نفسهم كمان لما كان
لهم في الوسط حتى الفني على مدار الكم سنه
اللي فاتوا ايام امر ممثل في الدراما بشكل
اساسي وكم تجربه سينمائيه لكن هو اليوم
بطل سينمائي كمان الصف الاخير فيلم من
بطولته ومعه بيومي فؤاد وبينافس مو بس في
دور السينما المصريه بالكمان دور السينما
العربيه وفي بيلعب تيام دور شاب قليل
الخبره بالحياه وبيشوف كل شيء يحوله من
زاويه واحده وبخوض رحله من يوم واحد بتقلب
له كل المفاهيم
يعني ايه اب ولا ام لا اخ ولا صديق
اكمل وليه يا ابني نكدت عليك ونكدت عليا
انا حاسس ان مشكلتك معايا انا مش مع
المسرحيه وانت بتتفرج على المسرحيه تقعد
في الصف الاخير مسرحيه بتحكي عن امير
وتغويه غنيه دي بقى لا موظف الكلمه يعني
واحده بتغني ولا بنت شمال
انت لابسه رشيد الدمنهوري ولا رشيد
الاسيوطي افخم انا شكلك سرق
ت والدتي طبعا من اكبر الداعمين له انتشرت
صور كثير لهم سوا في افتتاح الفيلم فيه
مصر وايام اليوم منورنا في تفاعلكم ولاول
مره عشان نتكلم عن الفيلم ومشواره لغايه
الان ومشاريعه المستقبليه كمان واللي فيه
من ضمنها مفاجاه حلوه ان كشف عنها من ايام
الينا من القاهره الفنان تيام مصطفى قمر
اهلا فيك معانا منورنا وخلينا اول شيء
نحسم الجدل هو تيام ولا تيام وايش معنى
الاسم
اوكي ايش يعني تيام
ايام جايه من متيم يعني على وزن فعال
حلو طيب وعلى السيره انت متيم
يعني
في بوادر
حلو طب احد مشهور
لا
بنهزر على فكره
لا لانه خلص بما انه دخلنا بموضوع الحب
وقلنا تيام ومتيم وكذا ما انت دايما في
اشاعات بتربطك بكثير من زميلاتك فخلينا
نخلص من ده الموضوع اشاعات ولا حقيقه
اشاعات كلها اشاعات مغرضه وكلنا اصحاب وما
فيش اي حاجه من الكلام ده طيب خلاص بما
انه هذا الكلام الاخير خلينا نتكلم عن
الفيلم الصف الاخير
احكيلنا عن هذا الفيلم تجربتك فيه اول
بطوله يعني لك
هو انا كنت متحمس جدا ان انا اعمل الفيلم
ده انا من زمان وانا نفسي ادخل السينما
قوي ان انا بحب السينما جدا فانا يعني
تحملت اكتر لما لقيت ان انا هبقى مع النجم
طبعا كبير قوي ده يوم فؤاد يعني انا بحبه
جدا ومن جمهوره واشتغلنا مع بعض قبل كده
في خيانه عهد وفارس بلا جواز بس ما
اشتغلناش مع بعض
بالانسان
انا انبسطت جدا بالتجربه دي والقصه كمان
كانت مختلفه ولذيذه
والفيلم فيه برده وجهه نظر فنيه كده انا
حطيت ان انا يعني بعمل حاجه مختلفه
للسينما فانا كنت مبسوط جدا ان ده دخولين
حسيت انه مختلف لانه يعني بيدور انه كذا
في يوم واحد ولا حسيت انه مختلف كمان لانه
القصه هل حسيت فيها تشابه بينك بينك وبين
الشاب اللي بتقدمه
يعني انا مش قريب قوي للشخصيه بس انا حبيت
الشخصيه جدا ولكن اللي انا حسيته مختلف
قوي هو فكره
الرساله اللي الفيلم عايز يوصلها
والانسانيه اللي موجوده في الفيلم فانا
حبيت قوي
ان يكون في في رساله انسانيه متوجهه
للمشاهد زائد ان الفيلم كمان عباره عن
رحله فدي حاجه لطيفه قوي ان المشاهد بياخذ
الرحله دي مع الكارت فدي برده كانت حاجه
لطيفه واضافه للفيلم وانا كمان انا اتفرجت
على الفيلم لاول مره في العرض الخاص يعني
انا ما شفتوش خالص ولا كنت بحب اتفرج في
النص فانا لما اتفرجت بقى في العرض الخاص
يعني انا انبسطت قوي حسيت ان انا فعلا
طالع الرحله دي معاهم طب حلوه ولما تفرجت
علي بما انك انت ما تفرجت عليه يعني وهو
لسه بيتمنتج والكلام هذا كله وتفاصيل هذه
لما شفتوا كده وانت جالس مع الجمهور كما
اعطيت نفسك من عشره
مش هقدر اقيم نفسي لا كده بس كده بينك
وبين نفسك قلت برافو يا تيام يعني يا ولد
دايما واطلع الحاجات اللي هو الحته دي
كانت ممكن تبقى احسن بس ممكن اخد دي من
طريقه مختلفه فعمري ما هكون مبسوط ميه في
الميه يعني
خليني اقول يعني انا كثير من الناس اللي
بقابلهم يعني مثلا بتجيهم البطوله بس
بتجيهم دايما يعني او غالبا خلينا نقول
متاخره فدائما بنسالهم انه يعني بتحس انك
انظلمت بتحس انك انت تاخرت عليك البطوله
في حالتك انت العكس انت ما شاء الله يعني
العمر كله ان شاء الله وفي بدايه المشوار
وما الى ذلك وما شاء الله جاتك البطوله
على طول ما خفت انه البطوله جايه بدري
وانا اولا بعتبر نفسي محظوظ جدا
وبحمد ربنا كل يوم على كل فرص اللي بتجيلي
ويا رب اكون قد الفرص دي وبحاول اهتم بكل
حاجه بتجيلي واديها 110% من من مجهودي
وتركيزي
ودائما حريص على ان كل حاجه بعملها هتكون
مختلفه وازهر الناس بشكل جديد فانا مش مش
مقتنع ان ان علشان انا في سن صغير جاتلي
فرص كويسه او انا عملت بطوله معناها ان ان
انا تركلي كل حاجه بعد كده
البطوله
مطلقه
انا انا عارف ان الدور هو اللي بيحكم
القصه هي اللي بتحكم فانا انا انا يعني ما
عنديش اي اعتراض ان الفيلم الجاي يبقى دور
اصغر بكثير او او حاجه اطلع بشكل مختلف
يعني مش علشان عملتها دلوقتي معناها ان هو
كده يعني خلينا كمان نكون واقعيين يعني في
السوق وفي الفن تحديدا كلنا الواحد يطلع
خطوه لازم يحافظ على الخطوه اللي اخذها اي
شيء خطوه ثانيه مثلا حتى تعتبر تراجع في
مسيرتك الفنيه وممكن تنفهم غلط سواء من
الجمهور او من زملائك اللي حوالينك اكيد
طبعا بس انا بعتبر الخطوات مش مش معناها
بس حجم الدور هي معناه نوعيه الدور وظهورك
للجمهور ده بيبقى شكله عامل ازاي وانت
بتقدم نفسك كممثل بطريقه شكلها عامل ازاي
فانا موضوع حجم الدور ده بيبقى اخر حاجه
ببص عليها لكن انا بفكر انا الخطوه دي
هتضيف لي ايه في في الكبير بتاعي او في
مسيرتي طيب بما انه يعني كنا بنتكلم عن
البطوله وانه كيف جاتك وبتعتبر نفسك محظوظ
وكده كمان كثير ناس بيقولوا صح تيام محظوظ
لانه في نفس الوقت ابن مصطفى قمر وابن هذا
الوسط الفني وصراحه يعني في الفتره
الاخيره الموضوع ما عاد مصادفه صراحه ما
شاء الله الوسط الفني كله اولاده دخلوا
السوق صراحه
ههه حقيقه يعني في البدايه كان واحد اثنين
الان لا خلاص كلكم دخلتوا فكيف بتحس تجاهل
الموضوع
والله يعني انا اول لما بدات امثل تاني
لما كبرت حسيت ان كان في
اولا سبوت لايت علي ان انا
دايما محطوط
[موسيقى]
العنوان بتاع ده ابنه مصطفى قمر فانا حسيت
اللي هو طيب انا بحاول اثبت نفسي كممثل
فانا طالما جات لي فرصه كويسه واولا هو
الفرص برده اللي بتيجي ما بتبقاش علشان ده
ابن مصطفى قمر فهناخده يعني انا مش مقتنع
خالص ان في حاجه اسمها تمثيل
يعني المخرج عمره ما هياخذني لو هو مش
مقتنع بيا لو هو شايف ان انا مش لايق على
الدور لو هو شايف ان انا هفشله ومش
هياخذني فهو انا هتاخد في دول علشان انا
اصلح للدور ده او هو المخرج ليه وجهه نظر
معين فانا
بحاول على قد ما اقدر ان انا اكون قد
الفرص دي وان انا دائما يعني
نجاحاتي
لمجهودي انا
وشطارتي
والانجي اللي انا بحطها في شغل فانا بحاول
على قد ما اقدر يعني انا كل حاجه عملتها
كان يعني المتسلسلات اللي انت قلتيها كلها
كانت بره بابا بابا
خليني اسالك انه على الفيلم الصف الاخير
الان بتحس انه انظلم مصريا اكثر من عربيه
يعني عربيا حصل على مشاهده اكبر
هو انا حاسس ان الفيلم ده من النوعيه اللي
هتوصل اكتر للجمهور على على منصه اكثر من
سينما مع انه متين كويس
اكتر بكتير قوي في الخليج وفي الامارات
فده برضو شيء يعني يساعدني جدا فانا حاسس
ان الفيلم ده ان شاء الله برضه لما يوصل
للناس بطريقه مختلفه الناس هتشوفه اكثر
وهيوصل لهم يعني اسرع طيب سريعا احكي لنا
عن اللي هو اولاد حريم كريم
الناس تحمست على الموضوع
انا انا انا اصلا كنت متحمس للترودك ده
جدا قبل ما اكون فيه فاول لما قالولي عايز
تبقى معنا في الفيلم انا تحمست اكتر ان
انا وبابا نفسنا من زمان قوي ان احنا
الاتنين نعمل مع بعض بس وبيتعدد علينا
كتير بس احنا مستنيين يكون حاجه تستاهل
وحاجه قويه
تحمسنا احنا الاتنين جدا للفرشه دي وانا
شايف ان الفيلم ده ان شاء الله يعني هيبقى
احلى من الاولاني ان هو
في نفس الابطال بتوع قبل كده استاذه داليا
البحيري
استاذه بسمه وفي ابطال جديده
استاذه بشرى واستاذ عمرو عبد الجليل
والشباب بقى كلهم
ان شاء الله يعني
هتكون تجربه ان شاء الله كلنا متحمسين لها
تيام انا بشكرك جدا على ظهورك معنا اليوم
وحقيقه يعني طريقه حوارك واجوبتك وادائك
اكبر من عمرك بكثير يا تيام فان شاء الله
بالتوفيق دائما ومن نجاح لنجاح يا رب منور
دائما كان معنا تيام مصطفى قمر مشاهدينا
في امان الله
[موسيقى]